欢迎收听赵华语古惑仔的周末特别版
通常周末我们会加开特别版
就是因为有特别的来宾
因为这一次我们的台股
真的是很戏剧性的一个表现
往下也戏剧性
往上反弹的时候也算是有某种戏剧性
那这一次我们有一次特别不一样的体验
是因为在下跌过程中
处置股的条款
让很多的公司它呈现无量下跌
导致有一些买中小型股的朋友是受伤惨重
那这一次的反弹又急又快
而处置股的调整
也让这个流动性开始变得比较好
所以到底算不算是利空已经顿化
或是过去而只会反应利多了呢
那一下子从看到39000
好害怕
到现在46000点左右的位阶
会不会已经弹过了
来不及了呢
当然不会
我们今天要讲的就是
当这样的一个变动发生
在台股市场是非常经常性的
可是如何能够提早做到预防
以及在底部出现的时候
能够勇敢的进场
他会需要非常好的一些知识
可是他并不难学
我先来欢迎今天的特别来宾
大家很熟悉的
第一位是K线之神朱家宏朱老师
大家好大家好
朱家宏老师
这熟到不行了
第二位当然是走图小天
我们的林颖老师
大家好我是林颖
每次在关键时刻两位出现
突然之间还没有开始访谈
就已经觉得吃了一个定心丸
不过我们先就现况来讲好了
因为这一次一反谈又是6000点上来
大家心境很可爱
前面在杀的时候
每一个人都觉得完了
这一次可能会一直跌
就会有很多预测
3万5千点
3万点这种言论都会跑出来
AI泡沫化
可是谈的时候又会说
哇那早知道就抄底
对不对
那如果现在这样的位阶
4万6千点以目前的技术图来说
是一个什么样的水位
现阶段的操作模式
是我们继续等会打搅
还是觉得我们就从里面找好的股票就对了
大盘在这一阵子的变化
其实大家虽然有经历过大涨大跌
实际上我相信大家也可以感受到很多经验
原来股票不是只会涨也会大跌的
但大跌完了它也会大涨
也会反弹
所以在这个变化中要怎么样掌握
这才是大家比较关心的
我怎么知道它要大跌了
如果我知道我一定先跑了
根本不知道哪一天
可是或者是就算我跑了
那我又怎么知道什么时候还可以再来买
所以这个才是大家所要关心
或者想要知道的
那实际上在我们股票市场
技术分析上
会反映市场的所有的讯息
可能市场上有人早知道了
这个大盘可能要杀了
所以市场就会去卖
卖的话在技术分析上
就会出现一个黑黑的下跌
这个是正常来讲
这叫多头的回档
因为长多了
本来就是有人获利就想跑了
我们比较重要的是说
趋势不要改变
本来多头找的好好的
回党以后每一次都创新高
每次都创新高
所以大家就失去了一个警戒
说这次回党应该还会再创高
所以就一直抱着
结果抱着抱着怎么这一次就一直跌
所以就损失惨重
其实大家去回头看一下
我们的7月7号
今天是8月
7月7号那天我们有一个黑K跌下来了
可是就趋势来讲
我们的大盘内贴已经进到盘整了
那进到盘整我们的资金就要调节了
比如说你满仓的
all in的
那时候最流行all in 三代 四代
好 上岗 我们讨论好几次
所以那时候要赶快减仓
大盘盘整要减到五成
比如说手上已经不涨的
跌的你就给它卖一卖
把钱收回来
到7月17号有一根长黑
我们大盘就转空了
所以实际上可以追溯到7月初7月中
我们的大盘就已经开始往下走了
如果你会看技术分析的K线这些变化
再加上趋势
你很早就已经知道大盘会跌
只是我们不知道会跌到哪里
因为跌到哪里也是市场来决定的
所以一直跌跌跌到我们的这个那天破4万
大家都想说大概完蛋了没机会了
那同样的在跌破4万那一天
拉了一个下影线
第二天就一路反攻
而且第二天是跳空
跳空大涨好几千点
它就反攻
所以那一天又告诉我们一个讯号
这边已经跌完了
它要开始反弹了
一直坦到今天
都还没有下来
所以就我们的技术面来讲
我们的大盘是一个强力反弹
它不但站上月线 站上季线
刚才讲已经到4万流
我们的历史高点也才4万8
对 差两千多点而已
所以一个反弹又好像快要回来了
所以在这个经历中
我相信大家是不是希望说
哎呀 我也可以知道7月初
我就先减码把钱收回来
那现在反弹我又有机会等股票来做
那有些股票当然比大盘反转的还要快
已经变多头
那你不妨现在又可以开始
用技术面已经转多的股票你去做
林玲老师也是觉得如果现阶段才进来去找转多的股票
依旧还算安全吗
我认为现在当然进场是很安全的
因为这波反弹有很多朋友问我说
他好可惜这波反弹没做到
大家都觉得自己是股神可以抄底在最低点
但是其实做不到
做不到啊
这本来就是做不到的事情嘛
那现在当然第一波反弹第一只脚很强嘛
所以我们现在就等待第二只脚
确认多头之后我们进场
会不会没有脚了
好多人在问这个事情
那其实我们在技术分析里面
朱老师有教过
如果他没有脚
其实K线横盘也视为一只脚
对 K线有可能会用以盘代跌
对 所以其实这两天很多股票
就是这个礼拜
很多股票都是K线横盘突破
那这一只脚一突破
股价在20日均线之上
20日均线向上
他就转成多头了
所以我倒会觉得说
过去的空头反弹
是给我们一个讯号
代表我的股价
强力急跌之后又急涨上来
那这个讯号告诉我
这只脚很强
所以代表后面的多头
我一定要好好把握
所以过去那个反弹
没做到也没关系
但多头没做到就不太应该了
因为我跟两位学到一个东西很重要
例如说那一天7月17号
一个大长黑
很多人就会觉得算了啦
我不要跑了
其实那是一个非常强力
告诉你盘要往下灌的讯号
很多人觉得那天跌那么多了
我就忍耐一下
是不是后面还有更低
还有就是7月31号反转那个大红K
很多说长那么多了那来不及了其实那就是一个网上很强力的讯号对两位来說 這兩個訊號其實強烈到不行對不對對 所以其實我們也講不要去摸底 不要摸頭
對 如果他多頭沒有出現頭頭低
我們本來就做多繼續做嘛 所以在那個時候
歷史高點回來的時候 我們還說回後買上漲
可以有機會再創歷史高點 是
可是7月7號就沒有了 因為他就是沒過去
所以我们对趋势还有这些K线的掌握
各位一定要把它精进
因为我们是散户
说实在话
很多一些早知道的消息
我们可能没有那么专业
甚至于国外的一些总经数据
或者产业的基本面
我们可能一般人没那么多时间
去研究到那么透彻
但是如果你能够把图看懂
你至少知道趋吉避凶
或者要避开风险
把这些位置如果能抓到的话
你至少不会搭配
这个其实蛮重要
因为大部分的散户
我今天下午5点钟
我们家门口丢垃圾
我还是要丢垃圾
虽然是老师
还是要丢垃圾
突然平民了起来
家里没有用人
就自己丢
每次丢垃圾
都是一大堆左右邻居
都提着带着那边
我今天就听到一个讲说
这次股票我本来赚钱
结果最近大赔就在那边讲
另外一个就说
做股票本来就这样子很难做
所以我的感觉
就是一般人做股票
他真的他就觉得说
我有赚 我有赔
可是不知道为什么赚
也不知道为什么会大赔掉
那如果能够知道这样子的话
又有一个好方法掌握
我相信你赚的时候会大赚
那你赔的时候你也跑掉了
我相信这是大家最想要知道的
我能够赚到钱
然后赔钱的时候我又不在
我又走掉
那就最厉害了
那实际上
如果你在技术分析上
能够掌握这些
我们讲转折
K线的转折讯号
你真的可以怎么样
可以有钱买到早知道
人家说难买早知道
但是你学了技术分析
你就可以知道
这根K线的讯号
我早知道我就该跑了
所以每一次的历史都会重演
都是这样
所以能够尽早的学会这些讯号
我相信你就可以掌握你自己手上那只股票
因为股票很多
你不可能去管到别人的股票
你把你手上这只股票的命运给它掌握住
那其实就是你在股市获利的最大机会
不过我这边想要再追问朱老师一件事
其实我印象很深
去年对等关税的这个板子拿出来暴跌钱
朱老师常常上理财达人秀嘛
就聊
他说其实大盘那时候就缓缓的
已经跌破了月线
所以再怎么说
手上的资金都要先减码到五成以下
对不对
那这一次除了刚刚讲的那一根转折大黑之外
有没有其他辅助让你觉得
要先把资金水位降低的讯号呢
好
我们一般是以这个大盘的位置
或者你做股票个股的位置
但是总资金的投入
就是以大盘来做我们总资金的控管
大盘多头都没有变
不管它怎么强
只要它多头
我们的资金可以加到七成八成
但原则上我们比较不希望大家all in
当然有时候机会太好
很多人忍不住了就all in
但是我们大概会到八成最多九成
那大盘我刚刚有讲
进到盘整我们就大概把它降到五成
那降到五成因为它盘整有时候时间短
有时候时间很长
那如果时间很长
你大概也知道这个盘并不是很理想
那空头一确认
如果我们只做多不做空的话
那你的资金要赶快降
要降到四成
然后再上不来就要降到三成
所以基本上我们前一阵子
跌到7月31号最低点的时候
应该你是三成的资金在股市里面
那这一阵子的反弹
我相信你很高兴
因为你有七成的资金
都是现金
然后你现在就可以选好的反转强势的股票
你就开始布局
但是因为大盘现在是反弹
它并不是盘整
所以如果你看到第二只脚
就像我们刚才头一样
你现在就可以变五成了
三成变五成了
那如果大盘真的把底液打出来了
多头也确认你又开始加码了
六成七成这样做
所以永远要顺到这个趋势的方向
调节手上的资金
这个好处就是说大跌的时候你心很安
因为你有七成资金在手上
那三成即使万一控制不好
那大概就是一个停损
那你有七成资金等现在好机会
其实我可以跟大家讲
我们的大盘现在
大家就在等最好的机会
因为它已经证明了
它开始转强了
这一路的反弹就在证明
这个低点已经没有了
就是类似破4万点的低点
那这样子我们如果再等它
把这个架构做好
就是趋势的架构做好
那我们就可以开始做股票
就可以操作股票
所以任何时候
只要你先具备好这些
技术分析的专业条件
它什么时候都会有机会
那你都可以用技术分析
在市场获利
好
这个是在大跌之前
朱老师会观察的一些指标
那这边要请教林玲老师
就是刚刚讲到
现在当然我们都会觉得
对啊
4万点那时候就是底了
不过这是事后论
当下发生的那一天
那除了后来隔天的一个大红K之外
林玲老师还有观察什么
因为我觉得这是
我自己个人比较困扰的是
一直没有看到所谓的底部大量这件事
而是用一个正常的中量
在微微往上推
所以你觉得当时候
如果想要进场稍微捞一点便宜股票的人
应该观察什么
我想其实在我们的技术分析里面
有一个底部触底条件
它是很明显的
就是说我们这一次在7月30号那一次
是不是受了一个十字变盘线
那7月29号出现一个大量长黑K
那我们把图在往前推
其实在29号之前
我们的大盘已经是
糖后下跌连续三根实体长黑K了
那在我们的K棒理论来讲
下跌连三黑
尤其是低档
它是很容易出现止跌讯号的
所以你把图打开
其实在7月29号
7月30号的时候
已经有三根长黑K下来
而且那三根长黑K威力都很强
几乎都是这种扫融资
扫断头
甚至我本身有在期货公司的同事
他说那个期货断头更可怕
就在那三天里面
不论是股票断头期货断头
但重点是这些断头的股票都集中在高价股因为这些高价股都是高档高融资的股票那一刹下来之后我就已经知道连续三根黑K下跌已经是短线空头的低档
再加上7月30号出现止跌的变盘线
这两根K棒是一个很重要的讯号
那这个重要讯号来自于它刚好在重要的支撑撑住了
这个重要支撑除了4万点之外
其实如果你把图打开
把图往左边看
它前面有个转折低
刚好也撑住
还有这一次的最低点
4万点 39000点
这次刚好碰到我们大盘的半年线
他刚好碰到向上的半年线
刚刚好都没有破
就一个十字变盘线最低点碰到
这都很厉害的
因为你最低点刚好碰到线
这代表有人控盘控在这里
那不然怎么会这么刚好
所以这根十字变盘线出来之后
其实我们就要有警觉了
可能大概杀到这里是差不多的
但最重要关键是隔天7月31号的
大量敞红棒
因为那根大量长虹棒是开盘跳空往上
那我们空方力道很强
它强到一个程度之后
竟然隔天开盘跳空收一个大长虹
那个是一个重要转折
即使没有量
但是在我们的技术分析领域里面
价格是最重要的
价格只要转折逆转往上的话
量后面都可以补出来的
所以或许我们可以学到一点就是
当我的股价连续下跌到低档
然后连续长黑下来
这些都是K棒的反应
那遇到重要支撑
而且三个重要支撑
我们刚刚有讲
包括你的半年线
你的前低还有整数关卡
他撑住了之后
有没有支撑就看隔天
结果7月31号
大量红可以转折往上
那就确认有支撑了
而且那根长红真的很厉害
所以在那种长红情况之下
你看融资又断头
讯号出来了
其实没有大量
可是扎扎实实
那个长红棒就是有人进场
这种位置我觉得
其实都可以逆势强一点反弹
是
当然那时候还要继续观察
是因为国际股市还在动荡
那时候因为这一波说实话
我们不是正央
正要从韩国来
还有美国可能担心会升起
这种外在的变数
所以虽然已经心里面也有底
但是要是可能也只是先小量
小量 对小量
所以我这边补充一下
刚才赵华讲
这一路上涨好像都没什么量
很担心
就是八九千亿的量
其实不用担心
不用担心了是不是
现在反而不要放大量
现在反而不要大量了
对 因为现在已经到上面来了
上面你一爆量就是反弹结束
反弹就结束了
但反弹结束好不好
好啊 我们就在等它结束
要不然每个人都说
老师这怎么办
都没办法追
所以最近大家就要注意一下
不要放出大量
你如果一放到1.2 1.5兆的话
那就麻烦了
它就要回档
那这回档是好啊
我们刚刚有讲
我们有纪律
如果它回档出来一个长黑
把五日均线跌破
那我们就准备看它什么时候完成第二只脚
那第二只脚我们又可以知道
它坐在什么地方
坐在哪个位置
那我们又可以再来推断
这个大盘未来是不是会很强
还是短期还要整理
那这都是因为我们在基础分析上
可以先去等待的
那我们如果把这些机会都能够掌握
大盘底部出来了
那我刚刚就讲资金可以加到五成了
加到五成甚至于好的股票会领先大盘吧
那你也可以先做了
因为大盘都不跌了
那我的股票是多嘛
当然我就可以先去开始去做股票了
其实很多人可能都会只看短短眼前几天
但股票是一辈子的事情
对不对
所以朱老师宁愿等到图是好的
不要觉得谈了就没了
就跟跌的时候觉得跌了就没了一样
不过这次我们台湾有个比较特殊的情况
就是我们有所谓的处置股制度啦
那大家又很集中在某些热门产业的时候
当下你就会觉得
我知道技术形态要我走了
可是我卖不掉
这真的很尴尬
不过幸好我们的制度改了
所以接下来我想整个盘面
用所谓的技术形态操作
它的准确度跟灵敏度
应该就可以完全地回来
那这一次我有身边有些好朋友
也开始觉得痛丁思痛哦
要学习
就有问我说
那朱老师跟林音老师的课程
能不能学得会
其实我自己有点犹豫
因为我自己是跟朱老师学
可是我就一直很半吊子
所以今天两位其实要讲的是
K棒它也可以是一个很简单
入门的百科
K棒是技术分析的基础
因为没有K棒什么都没有
所以本来就要把K棒
把它弄得很清楚
每根K棒的变化
它代表什么讯号
然后你在配合趋势
你的位置
那你自然对股票的所有的都可以做一个掌握
那第二个我在讲
技术分析男与老少不分年纪大小都会学会的
因为他真的没有高升学问
明明就有点还是需要专心学
而且纪律
纪律最重要
他不像我们在学校读书
又是数学又是国文又是这个考试
他都没有
就是你学了这个一个规则
那你按照这个规则
再去练习
你慢慢就可以掌握
这个技术分析的诀窍了
所以技术分析任何人都可以学
那我就讲大家都知道
我57岁才学
我也不是二三十岁去学技术分析
但是因为我57岁是五岁游民
所以我比较专心学
就是每天都在上课
每天都在那个
那有些人因为工作忙
或怎么样
可能就没有办法
这个去教室或上课
所以我跟林玲老师也就特别说
去开发这个所谓的线上的影音课
你晚上回来有空
你就看个半小时
然后你一天干一天
大概两个礼拜你也全部看完了
好像全部的课都上过一遍
所以现在的资讯发达
网络发达
大家的学习应该是更简单了
而且还有一个好处
以前我去上课的时候
如果听不懂或怎么样
那就下一期再报名
那现在的影音课你可以重复看
那真的
只要你有心学
真的不怕学不会
可以重复看
可以问你们问题吗
有
有群组服务
现在都有群组服务
你还有人帮你解答
或者是你有问题都帮你解答
所以只要你有心学
课程内容都很浅显易懂
就是你一定听得懂
你不会说听不懂的
那重点就是你学完了
要在股市里面实物经验上
你要多去验证
你每一次验证
那久了你就有心得了
你就会抓到这些上涨下跌的位置
那以后你做股票
绝对不会像现在那么痛苦
赚上去也不知道什么时候买
跌下来也不知道什么时候买
然后被套牢也不知道什么时候解套
反正大概就是一般散户的问题
你都可以有K线你能够看懂的话這些應該都會解決好 因為我們今天我也特地幫大家這一堂課叫做K線實戰百科
我有列出一些
可能投資朋友手上會有的股票
讓兩位空中稍微解讀一下
因為像南亞科創歷史新高
可是像華邦店望虹就還沒有
所以要不要挑其中一檔
來幫大家走圖一下說
華邦店望虹
目前有没有谁是反弹到这边还值得介入的
好 我们看好了
滑邦店因为它价位比较低一点
这个切入也比较容易
其实滑邦店我们先讲
有的人买在高点现在还在等解套
对不对
但是如果你用我们的K线的转折的话
一样6月22号就是最高点的那根黑K
然后第二天就跌下来了
但第三天6月25号它又上去了
然后6月26号又一个黑K下来
这就是我刚刚讲的
不管你是大盘
不管你是股票
你已经出现头头的了
就是说它已经到盘整了
换句话说
这支股票如果你空手
你就不能来买了
如果你是有多单
你应该要走了
所以你看你在那时候走的时候
大概是220了
那后来跌到120了
你看这个差距有多大
你那时候走了
你留了这个220
就是留了22万
那你现在下来的话
120了
你可以买两张
对不对
差不多可以买两张
前面就有信号是可以离场
它是来得及离场的
那现在就是
好了
这事情已经过了
那我现在
那既然这样子
它又转强了
我什么时候来买
所以7月30号
它就跟着我们的大盘
7月30号就最低点
而且它留了一个很长的上影线
换句话讲
那天就出现了
超级大量的变盘线
那我们就要注意第二天
第二天它跳空
因为大盘跳它就涨停了
所以好多股票
不怕没有人要的
因为你跌得那么深
它又好哪个不要
每个都要抢
大盘一转强第二天就涨停
它从第二天一直到今天
它都没有跌破五日均线
换句话说它沿着五日均线走
但是有一个讯号很强烈
他8月10号把7月23号的高点突破了
换句话讲他现在也不是空头了
他变头头高了
那现在我们要做这支股票很简单
就跟大凡一样等第二只脚就好了
我们大凡也是突破前高了
昨天上节目就是突破前高了
那今天继续突破
那我们现在只要他第二只脚完成
他就变多了
那我们又可以开始做他
所以像这个股票
大家就看他什么时候回来
不过这两天已经有回来的讯号
因为连续两天都黑K
代表这个地方它要回档
那我们就把钱准备好
然后你看它回档
只要它的架构没变
月线不要跌破
那我们就可以开始做了
好 所以这是记忆体选了华邦店来聊
还有我想PCB上游
我也是被问到
我决定把问题转嫁
就是所谓做高阶同伯的京居
京居也是之前寄予厚望之后
它是不止腰斩
可能还打到三者四者
那最近也有一些反攻
但反攻力道还是偏弱
好 那我们先看
先了解一下到底
有没有高档的讯号
可以让我们先
高档先获利了解
你卖在高档绝对是赚钱跑的
可是你卖在低档
绝对是赔钱跑的
所以我们在要出场的时候
或者是我们赚很多的时候
你永远要去注意K棒的讯号
因为K棒永远就是主力的讯号
我们很难去知道
主力什么时候要进出场
可是K棒可以告诉我们
所以你可以看技术分析图
6月22号的那一天
它高档最高点758块
已经出现了一个长上影线
在我们的技术分析里面
长上影线就代表已经
拉高有人在出货了
因为它拉最高又杀低
那第二天就不能跌了
因为第二天只要一跌下来
那就证明我昨天是有人在卖股票
所以6月23号那一天
长黑下跌
长黑下跌就把6月22号的
上影线的K棒的低点跌破
这一跌破那糟糕了
高档形成一个高档的夜星组合
这个K棒的三根K棒组合
这个也会在实战百科交吗
会
而且这个夜星是反转力道最强的夜星组合
而且你仔细看它还有量价背离
所以这种的现象
其实如果你手上有这档股票
有这个金均
在6月23号那一天
你应该就多单要出场
因为6月23号那一天也跌破五军
多头回档
那你本来就应该要跑了
假设你不跑也凹单
你想说好一根没关系
我就在凹一下反正我做长线
最慢其实在接下来的两三天
它跌破月线
而且它破月线也是一根大量长黑破
这一破下来
破月线又大量长黑
这个股票真的已经不行了
因为跌破月线
我们的多头就已经转弱了
只要一转弱
而且你这股票很飙
你很飙
连续三天出现高档月薪又跌破月线
这都已经是主力在这一个礼拜全部卖光了
所以我们在K棒里面可以看到这些讯号
所以你最慢跌破月线那根K棒也要出场
那最后这个最不得已的情况
在7月7号空头确认
那你就连长单都要出场了
所以如果你能够把握这几个日子
这几根长黑K棒
那你在操作上我想
你至少好歹最慢也卖在500块
差不多吗
不过500块已经很多人反应很痛了
但你看到现在270都是要去撞墙了
但是有弹上来了
那现在形态好了吗
我们来看反弹
跌到270开始做反弹
但你就发现如果在最近的时间
各种股票的反弹来看它是弱的
很多股票都强力反弹
可是它的角度很平缓
而且它反弹到月线就有压
重点是它的月线很陡
所以我们看到我们的K棒也很清楚的知道
我们的红K反弹到月线就出黑K
而且还是一根长黑
这个黑K我们可以把它视为是一个长黑的覆盖线
那覆盖线一下来
我股价跌破了五均
当然我在8月11号这一天有出现底底高
那8月12号用跳空把前高给过
就转成多头确认了
可是它还是弱
因为月线还在向下
更何况再往上寄线也是压力
所以如果就同时间空头反弹的股票比较起来
这波跌幅太大了
跌幅太大
这个多方的力道如果短时间之内没有快速回来
其实虽然它还是多头
但这个多头就是比别人弱
那如果两箱比较起来
我们可能会去买那种比较强力反弹的股票
来去做操作
好
大家如果在听这一集的时候
不妨也可以拿出手上滑邦店跟京居的限图
假如您刚好这两档的话
来对照一下
刚刚一边听一边帮您做走图说明
然后这样的如果有兴趣的话
也可以来上一下这一堂
所谓的K线实战百科
好那今天非常谢谢
朱老师还有林音老师
就跟我们古获仔的朋友说拜拜咯
拜拜